We've worked with frosted cake, but sometimes it might be better to know how
much cake was not frosted. Let's look at a simple case of this. If 2 3rds of a
cake is frosted with vanilla icing, what fraction is not frosted? Well, let's
start off by looking at a cake. Here is a whole chocolate cake and I'm going to
ice 2 3rds of it. So I've split my cake up into 3rds and I iced two of those
3rds. Here is 1 3rds and 2 3rds. One way to think about this is that the parts
must add up to the whole. I know that I have 2 3rds of the cake frosted in
vanilla icing and I have to add some amount to get a whole cake. So I know 2
3rds plus some amount has to equal one. Well, this last piece is just 1 3rd, so
I can just put 1 3rd here. This is the amount that's not frosted. And remember
back from adding fractions, we know we just need to count up the 3rds. I have 1
3rd, 2 3rds, and 3 3rds altogether. So, this piece that's not frosted is 1 3rd.
There's actually another way that we can think about this. Let's instead start
with a whole cake and subtract off the parts that we don't want. We don't want
the vanilla icing. So let's subtract the pieces we don't want from the entire
whole cake. I started with one whole cake and I'm subtracting off 2 3rds. Well,
I know one whole cake is the same thing as 3 3rds. Remember, I can write one as
1 divided by 1, beecause that's still one., and then I can multiply this
fraction by 3 over 3. I'm just going to turn one into 3rds or 3 3rds, so I have
3 3rds minus 2 3rds which is 1 3rd. 1 3rd of my cake is not frosted. And what's
interesting about fractions is that it doesn't matter how much cake we're
talking about. We could have started with a different cake, maybe we started
with a rectangular cake. Here is a rectangular cake and I'm going to ice 2 3rds
of it. Doing the same problem with the rectangular cake doesn't change my
answer. I still have 2 3rds of it frosted in vanilla icing and 1 3rd that's left
unfrosted. The amount of cake that's frosted or unfrosted depends on the size
and shape of the original cake. The neat thing about fractions is that 2 3rds
could describe this part of a round cake or this part of a rectangular cake.
Fractions describe a part of a whole object.